- [Instructor] For a
generic redox reaction
where the reactants
turn into the products,
the free energy is
related to the potential
for the redox reaction.
The equation that relates free energy
and potential is given by delta G is equal
to negative nFE.
Delta G is the instantaneous
difference in free energy
between the reactants and the products
and refers to the number of electrons
that are transferred
in the redox reaction.
F is Faraday's constant,
which tells us the charge
carried by one mole of electrons.
So one mole of electrons
carries 96,485 coulombs.
E refers to the potential
of the redox reaction.
You could also call this the
voltage of the redox reaction.
If the reactants and products are both
in their standard states,
we can add the superscript
naught to delta G
and the superscript naught to E.
So we can use this equation
to calculate delta G naught
from E naught or vice versa.
We could calculate E
naught from delta G naught.
And remember that delta
G naught is connected
to the equilibrium constant
K by this equation.
Delta G naught is equal to
negative RT natural log of K,
where R is the ideal gas constant
and T is the temperature.
And because delta G naught is a part
of both of these two equations,
these two equations connect
the standard potential E naught
to the standard change in
free energy delta G naught,
which is then connected to
the equilibrium constant K.
So let's look at an
example of a redox reaction
where we know the value for the
standard potential E naught,
and first we're gonna
calculate delta G naught.
And then from delta G naught,
we're gonna calculate the
equilibrium constant K.
So here's our redox reaction,
and we're gonna calculate delta G naught
at 25 degrees Celsius from E naught.
So for this redox reaction,
E naught is equal to positive 1.54 volts,
and our goal is to
calculate delta G naught
at 25 degrees Celsius.
In our redox reaction,
silver one plus is being
reduced to solid silver,
and solid chromium is being oxidized
to chromium three plus.
Now that we've identified
what's being oxidized
and what's being reduced,
let's write the oxidation
and reduction half reactions.
So for our reduction half reaction,
we have silver one plus
gaining an electron
to form solid silver.
And for the oxidation half reaction,
solid chromium is turning
into chromium three plus
and losing three electrons.
Next, we need to figure out
how many electrons are being transferred
in our redox reaction.
In the reduction half reaction,
the silver one plus cation
is gaining an electron,
but in the oxidation half reaction,
solid chromium is losing three electrons.
And we need to make the
number of electrons equal.
Therefore, we need to multiply
the first half reaction
through by a factor of three.
So now when we add together our reactants,
so all the reactants on one side
and all the products on the other side,
the three electrons cancel out
and give us our overall redox reaction.
Because three electrons,
three moles of electrons
were being transferred
in our redox reaction,
n is equal to three.
And since we know that n is equal to three
and the standard potential
is equal to +1.54 volts,
we're ready to plug into our equation
to calculate delta G naught.
So I went ahead and
rewrote our redox reaction,
and our goal is to
calculate delta G naught.
We already know what n is,
we already know what E naught is,
and F is Faraday's constant.
Here's our equation with
everything plugged in.
N is equal to three.
There were three moles
of electrons transferred
in our redox reaction
per mole of reaction.
F is Faraday's constant,
which is 96,485 coulombs
per mole of electrons.
And the standard voltage
was equal to 1.54 volts.
One volt is equal to
one joule per coulomb,
so I went ahead and changed the units
from volts to joules per coulomb.
Next, we can cancel out some units.
So moles of electrons will cancel out,
and coulombs will cancel out,
and that gives us joules
per mole of reaction.
And after we do the math,
we find that delta G naught
at 25 degrees Celsius
for this redox reaction is equal
to -4.46 times 10 to the 5th joules
per mole of reaction.
We could also write this
in terms of kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
So delta G naught is equal
to -446 kilojoules per mole of reaction.
Notice that a positive voltage
and the negative in the equation means
that we get a negative
sign in the final answer.
And when delta G naught is negative,
the reaction is thermodynamically favored,
which means at 25 degrees Celsius,
silver cations will
react with solid chromium
to form solid silver and
chromium three plus ions.
And what this example shows us is
whenever the voltage is positive,
that means a thermodynamically
favored reaction
because delta G naught will be negative.
Now that we've calculated delta
G naught for our reaction,
let's calculate the equilibrium constant K
at 25 degrees Celsius.
So we need to plug in our
value for delta G naught,
the ideal gas constant,
the temperature in Kelvin,
and we'll solve for the
equilibrium constant.
I've gone ahead and plugged
everything into our equation.
So here's the value for delta G naught
in joules per mole of reaction.
The ideal gas constant
is equal to 8.314 joules
per Kelvin mole of reaction.
And 25 degrees Celsius,
if we add 273 to that,
we get 298 Kelvin.
Looking at the units, Kelvin cancels out
and so does joules per mole of reaction.
And solving for K,
the equilibrium constant
is approximately equal
to 10 to the 78th power.
And since K is such an
extremely large number,
that tells us the reaction
essentially goes to completion,
and all the reactants turn into products.
So for a reaction like this,
it's not necessary to have
equilibrium arrows in here.
We can just draw an
arrow going to the right.
And remember, we started with
a positive standard potential
for this redox reaction.
So to summarize what we've
seen with these calculations,
a positive value for the
standard potential leads
to a negative value for delta G naught,
so a thermodynamically
favored redox reaction.
And a negative value
for delta G naught leads
to an equilibrium constant
K that is greater than one.
We've just seen what
happens to delta G naught
and the equilibrium constant K
when the standard potential is positive
or greater than zero.
Now let's think about a
generic redox reaction
where the standard potential is negative,
so E naught is less than zero.
So let's think about the
sign for delta G naught
if we plug in a negative value
for the standard potential.
So if we have a negative voltage,
the two negative signs in the equation
will give us a positive
value for delta G naught.
A positive value for delta G naught means
that the forward reaction
of reactants turning into products
is a thermodynamically
unfavorable reaction.
And if we were to plug in a positive value
for delta G naught,
we would find that the
equilibrium constant K
would be less than one.
And when K is less than one,
that tells us whenever the
reaction reaches equilibrium,
there will be a lot more
reactants than products.
Let's look at a quick summary
of what we've learned from these examples.
The standard potential E naught
and the standard change in
free energy delta G naught
are related by the equation on the left.
And delta G naught
and the equilibrium constant K are related
by the equation on the right.
When E naught is greater than zero,
delta G naught is less than zero,
and the reaction is
thermodynamically favored,
which means at equilibrium,
there'll be more products than reactants,
and the equilibrium constant
K will be greater than one.
However, when E naught is less than zero,
delta G naught is greater than zero,
and the reaction is
thermodynamically unfavored,
which means at equilibrium,
there'll be more reactants than products,
and the equilibrium constant
K will be less than one.